added you have to have strength
to have suffered the same for me from the
end of vi
the man has a future
youth scripts
my name is robert barcia i am the
only author well your hard i felt
they  go the forces added
I was 5 years old
so at partys 166 there were things the
city of sète
[Music]
but I started you at the festivities of
the inauguration of the port of the city of
sète so it was the party of  the villa
is fun no words
adds that in order to be serious it
becomes a sport and after that becomes
a custom the tradition a culture
[Music]
in the nature of games it's not a
team
it's  to say that any independent man and
at the exit that this alone there are two
boats to think all the same that there are ten
rowers on the bench
there is a certain strength when we arrive
at the added face to face to or that's a
lot of  speed and a lot of weight
the player him he sort of
falls that means that to the queen
it's due  winning more or less away is
at my father's jousting tournament I shoot
my son play your little way and
I hope that the great-grandson everything is
a pair christophe ambitious yes
I have been an author since I was little my father
tells me  took alone aboard cairo
to go watch it i wanted to do
like my father
let's put on the stage louise it's the most
beautiful tournament that is danuta we win the
lace louis tmp of the world i put myself in
my bubble at 3  -4 minutes before the quarter
axelera you have to motivate yourself to type
in the guy you must not be afraid you
have to add three of their purchases for
what is done to the rich
we are a little disappointed when it is heavy for me
but  is always said
and then we will try to do better
lost but there it is a lot of graces
and mastics the war
the jousts his legs herman of
gagnières it is to participate and
live what his traditions of this folklore
of our city will certainly have  a pleasure
to the dead
how to ignore in life recipes i
I'm magnifying it means I'm enjoying myself
[Music]
[Applause]